bonjour david rigoulet roze merci de
répondre à nos questions ce matin sur
rtl france hassan un roi ni qui lance un
appel à un joe biden si ce dernier est
confirmé à la maison blanche par les
grands électeurs américains à quel
diplomatie faut-il s'attendre de la part
de washington vis-à-vis de téhéran comme
le souligner votre reportage il ya pour
l'instant il ya un certain flou qui
prévaut parce que la leur sur la forme
incontestablement il y aura sûrement une
différence par rapport à l'agressivité
martial du président entre l'ancien
président tron
mais aujourd'hui est lancée en sait
encore peu de choses sur la définition
de la problématique iranienne ce que ce
que joe biden a annoncé qu'il avait
l'intention de réintégrer le dgi six
points sur le principe dès lors que les
iraniens reviendrait sur le raid et
j'engage rapport que tout le monde sache
à un faible c'est l'accord de vianne en
2000 radenac donald trump pour mai 2018
a déchiré oui absolument c'est la corse
on est clair que de nom de notre un peu
s'était retirée unilatéralement donc sur
le principe il envisage bien de
réintégrer cet accord mais il est
certain qu'on ne reviendrait pas de
toute façon la situation était
d'ailleurs donald trump a fait en sorte
qu' il ya un point de non retour avec
l'accélération des sanctions qui ont été
qui ont été lancés après ce retrait donc
il ya effectivement sur la forme du rail
aura des différences y aura une logique
plus beaucoup plus multilatérale avec
les alliés occidentaux n'est les états
unis mais sur le fond il n'est pas sûr
que y est on revienne à une politique
tout à fait différent tout simplement
parce que joe biden de toute façon on
peut pas se permettre d'apparaître comme
faible vis à vis de l'iran
et d'ailleurs il a évoqué la
renégociation d'un accord avec des
clauses plus restrictives que celles
justement prévu par par l'accord de 2015
alors du coup il y avait un accord plus
restrictif mais s'il revient dans le
dissiper au ray
ça semble ça semble fou au final qu'est
ce qui peut se passer concrètement
est-ce qu'il peut y avoir également une
discussion avec les autres signataires
un dieu de l'accord de vienne savoir la
france la russie notamment
et les sanctions la fin des sanctions
c'est possible alors c'est ce que
demande évidemment l'iran comme gage de
bonne volonté c'est de revenir sur les
sanctions mais de toute façon le nouveau
président pourra pas comme ça supprimer
les sanctions qui ont été qui ont été
établies par lampard le président tron
tout simplement parce qu'il va devoir
tenir compte du congrès et qu'il ya un
sentiment qui est très fort au congrès
américain de toute façon et puis par
ailleurs il y aura une convergence avec
les européens c'est certain d'ailleurs
sur le fond ça rejoint assez
sensiblement le la stratégie qui avait
été celle du président macron des quatre
piliers avant la sortie des états unis
en mai 2018 c'est à dire le maintien de
l'ancien accord la renégociation de
cette clause c'est à dire les clauses
que crépusculaire qui ont qui sont le
fond du problème à savoir la levée de
l'embargo est déjà effective sur les
armes conventionnelles et puis les
échéances de 2023 2025 et 2030 et et là
on retrouve effectivement l'esprit des
quatre piliers du président macron avec
le rôle déstabilisateur aussi supposer
l'iran dans la région et et la question
très sensible du balistique
donc il ya ça va être la couette un
siècle pour le nouveau président de un
job haydn avec en réalité en arrière
plan un défi qui est le l'affrontement
stratégique avec la chine est l'objectif
de toute façon d'un éventuel deal c'est
d'empêcher une certaine manière avec la
guerre froide au fil avec la chine que
l'iran passe à l'est et la question est
posée depuis l'annoncé d'un accord
stratégique d'un partenariat stratégique
entre t en et pékin annoncé à l'été
dernier et comment la probable élection
de joe biden est elle perçue par le
peuple iranien
espoir méfiance oui circonspection va
dire effectivement le fait que le
président donald trump ne soit pas réélu
est un soulagement sans conteste mais en
même temps le guide suprême a évoqué le
fait que la présidence
n'aura aucun effet sur la politique
iranienne sur le fond et le problème
c'est que les iraniens se sont
désengagés peu par étapes
justement de leurs obligations vis-à-vis
de l'accord et que pour qu'il sort qui
leur reviennent dans l'accord sous les
formes qu'ils avaient été celles prévues
par logistic y aura ça va ça va demander
tractations extrêmement compliqué entre
washington et téhéran à supposer qu'elle
puisse se faire merci david rigoulet
roze d'abord répondu à nos questions je
rappelle que vous êtes enseignant
chercheur associé notamment à l'iris
institut des relations internationales
et stratégiques et docteur également en
sciences politiques notamment